[Aplausos]
[Música]
el viernes 28 de junio de 2019 ocurrió
algo que nunca pensamos iba a ocurrir se
anunció que la comisión europea había
alcanzado un acuerdo con mercosur para
crear el mayor acuerdo de libre comercio
de toda su historia y amigos la euforia
al otro lado del atlántico no fue menor
para nosotros también es un día
histórico este es el acuerdo más
importante que hemos firmado en nuestra
historia
estamos siendo debilitados y a ciegas a
un acuerdo que será muy difícil que
modifique las condiciones del trabajo en
argentina
20 largos años ha costado alcanzar un
acuerdo que afecta a una población de
casi 800 millones de personas y una
cuarta parte del pib mundial
amigos el acuerdo alcanzado pondrá en
marcha un tratado de libre comercio de
los llamados de nueva generación esto es
que se ocupará tanto del comercio como
de muchas otras cuestiones que tienen
que ver con las regulaciones públicas
pero cómo afectará este acuerdo a
latinoamérica qué beneficios y que
riesgos plantea como día entre se ha
tardado tanto queridos amigos de visual
política vamos a contestar a estas
preguntas pero antes antes tenemos que
saber qué es exactamente mercosur y qué
papel ha jugado desde su fundación ha
sido mercosur un éxito o un experimento
fallido
[Música]
un mercado común para américa
el historial latinoamericano de procesos
de integración regional es tan largo
como errático hay que remontarse muy
pero que muy atrás en el tiempo ni más
ni menos que hasta los años cincuenta
para encontrar los primeros intentos de
unir económica y comercialmente a todos
los países de américa latina' es decir
para crear algo así como un mercado
común donde se pudiera comprar vender
invertir o moverse sin que las fronteras
nacionales se pusieran ningún obstáculo
ya os adelanto que 60 años más tarde se
sigue teniendo el mismo debate y los
mismos objetivos así que bueno os podéis
imaginar que algo pues no ha ido bien
el caso es que entre otros organismos en
febrero de 1960 se firmó el tratado de
montevideo que creaba la asociación
latinoamericana de libre comercio la
apuesta más ambiciosa estaba integrado
por las diez repúblicas sudamericanas
junto con mexico y tenía una misión muy
clara eliminar todos los aranceles y la
mayoría de las trabas al comercio
regional en un plazo máximo de 10 años
desafortunadamente nunca se alcanzó esa
meta
sin embargo amigos mientras en américa
latina' el proceso de integración
económica avanzaba más lento que una
tortuga con reuma casi como esa canción
de ricky martin que decía eso de un
pasito para ante maría un pasito para
atrás el resto del mundo no se estuvo
quieto
durante la década de los 70 80 y los 90
el proyecto de integración europea
continuó creciendo a finales de los 80
se plantearon los cimientos del futuro
nafta el acuerdo de libre comercio entre
canadá estados unidos y méxico
the world on the wire
brumby que muestra dispersas distintas
y durante esos mismos años los países
asiáticos se lanzaron a comerse el
mercado mundial en general durante las
décadas de los 70 80 y 90 en todo el
mundo se avance un montón en esa idea de
impulsar el comercio internacional lo
que más tarde hemos conocido como
globalización e incluso en el año 1986
dio arranque la ronda uruguay que
terminaría creando una organización
mundial del comercio
tal vez fue esa especie de frenesí
internacional junto a las crisis
económicas latinoamericanas lo que
finalmente animó a los gobiernos de
brasil argentina uruguay y paraguay a
firmar el día 26 de marzo del año 1991
el tratado de asunción el tratado
constitutivo del mercado común del sur
mercosur consejo del mercado común
órgano superior encargado de la
conducción política
claro que un momento amigos porque una
cosa son las intenciones y otra muy
distinta los resultados casi 33 décadas
después a pesar de su nombre el mercado
común del sur mercosur ni siquiera ha
conseguido convertirse en un mercado
común y ese no es ni el único ni el peor
de sus problemas atentos
en función del protocolo compras
gubernamentales del sur mercosur el
quiero y no quiero
hagamos un ejercicio tomemos los datos y
que nos encontramos pues que sobre la
mesa mercosur es un espacio económico
enorme
hablamos de una organización que afecta
a casi 13 millones de kilómetros
cuadrados casi 300 millones de
habitantes y más de tres cuartas partes
del pib de toda américa del sur casi 3
billones de dólares tal y como veis
mercosur lo tenía todo para convertirse
en uno de los grandes mercados del
planeta sin embargo amigos con el paso
del tiempo si algo ha demostrado ha sido
precisamente sus limitaciones
[Música]
y esto es algo que tiene mucho pero que
mucho que ver con el propio espíritu con
el que nacieron los movimientos de
integración económica en américa latina'
veréis me explico desde que todos estos
procesos se pusieron sobre la mesa se
basaban en lo que se ha conocido como
regionalismo cerrado es decir eliminar
los aranceles al comercio dentro del
bloque pero eso sí mantener e incluso
incrementar los aranceles hacia el resto
del mundo
en el caso de mercosur eso se hizo
mediante el llamado arancel externo
común un arancel común para las
importaciones que tienen su origen fuera
del mercosur con él se pretendía
favorecer el comercio intrarregional
encareciendo con un arancel alto del 15
el venta o incluso el 30% las
importaciones de fuera del bloque
claro que eso evidentemente es algo que
tuvo consecuencias si esta barrera puede
que ayudase a algunos productores
locales como por ejemplo a los
productores de trigo argentinos pero con
carácter general todas estas
restricciones frenaron a la inversión
internacional hicieron que comprar
tecnología fuera muchísimo más caro y
también impidió que los países de
mercosur se integrarán en las cadenas de
producción internacionales y es que
aunque muchos políticos no se enteren
así es como funciona el mundo cada parte
de un producto se hace en un lugar
diferente
de esta forma claro se impide eso
castigas con aranceles la llegada de los
suministros que necesitan los
fabricantes pues te quedas fuera pero
ahí no termina todo al final claro pues
si defiendes el proteccionismo con el
resto del mundo cómo diantres no vas a
terminar haciéndolo con tus propios
vecinos y eso es en cierto modo lo que
ha pasado con mercosur que ha sido
incapaz de crear un verdadero mercado
común porque al final ni los diferentes
gobiernos de brasil ni los diferentes
gobiernos argentinos han creído nunca en
el comercio internacional como
herramienta para crecer y eso es lo que
precisamente ha provocado que a
diferencia por ejemplo
europea las aduanas entre los propios
países integrantes del mercosur no hayan
desaparecido argentina y uruguay son
miembros del mercosur en teoría las
fronteras internas no deberían existir
en mercosur sin embargo en la práctica
las aduanas las inspecciones sanitarias
y otros documentos implican que los
camiones tardan en cruzar la frontera
hasta 24 horas
oscar terzaghi para the economist
pero queréis otro ejemplo pues os voy a
hacer otra pregunta a ver si las spice
veréis china es el país al que argentina
le aplica más medidas antidumping para
dificultar las importaciones sea breeze
decirme cuál es el segundo país de todo
el planeta al que argentina aplica más
medidas 'antidumping' 123 puede que os
sorprenda pero la respuesta es ni más ni
menos que brasil si lo habéis escuchado
bien con sorpresas y quien quiere
enemigos se suele simplificar mucho el
debate pero lo cierto es que el comercio
no sólo depende de los aranceles para
nada de hecho en américa latina en
general hay pocos aranceles al comercio
regional pero amigos las restricciones
al comercio van mucho más allá derechos
antidumping el exigir y no concederá
automáticamente licencias a la
importación intervenciones en el tipo de
cambio reglas de origen etcétera
etcétera
a la hora de la verdad los gobiernos
tienen mucho margen de maniobra cuando
no existe un verdadero mercado común al
final entre unas cosas y otras los
líderes políticos de mercosur han
conseguido que ésta sea una de las áreas
comerciales menos integradas de todo el
planeta tienes que ponerte a buscar muy
a fondo para encontrar otro acuerdo
comercial con tan poco crecimiento
intrarregional como mercosur y el motor
osas argentina ha aplicado cuánta medida
proteccionista ha podido contra los
demás miembros y el brasil tampoco ha
puesto mucho de su parte roberto caicedo
de hecho fijaos cómo han evolucionado
los últimos años las exportaciones de
argentina-brasil
[Música]
sin embargo espera un momento porque
ahora todo esto parece estar por fin
cambiando y es justo ahí donde se
enmarca el acuerdo con la unión europea
tardamos 20 años pero logramos llegar un
momento en el tiempo en el cual
encontramos muchos líderes con buena
voluntad para transformar en esto es una
realidad hacia un nuevo mercosur
mercosur nació herido vale más allá de
los grandilocuentes discursos políticos
lo cierto es que nunca se tuvo la
esperanza de conseguir un gran resultado
eso sí cuidado a pesar de todos los
primeros años no fueron nada pero que
nada malo es el peso del comercio entre
los países de mercosur se multiplicó por
tres pasos del 8% de todo el comercio en
el año 1991 al 25% en 1998 es decir que
podríamos decir que todo apuntaba a que
a pesar de las limitaciones las cosas
podrían ir razonablemente bien
[Música]
sin embargo amigos a partir del año 2000
todo se complicó mucho los nuevos
líderes políticos que llegaron a
latinoamérica néstor kirchner lula silva
y tabaré vázquez cambiaron la idea
económica de mercosur para convertirlo
fundamentalmente en un órgano político
incluso se creó su propio parlamento el
parlamento del mercosur entonces del
regionalismo cerrado se pasó a lo que
los propios teóricos de izquierdas han
denominado el regionalismo post
hegemónico lo que no está muy claro qué
significa fue precisamente en esta época
cuando argentina-brasil de uruguay
dieron la bienvenida a mercosur a la
venezuela de hugo chávez y también
comenzó el proceso de adhesión de
bolivia aunque eso sí en 2017 venezuela
fue suspendida por tiempo indefinido el
caso es que de esta forma cuando
mercosur no había aún conseguido la
integración económica pues se dio
carpetazo a la economía de tal forma que
una organización que se llama un mercado
del sur pasó a ser casi de todo excepto
un mercado integrado
así es como del 25% de todo el comercio
que sus países miembros en 1998 el peso
del mercosur volvió a caer hasta poco
más del 13 por ciento en 2017 para que
os hagáis una idea esta cifra en la
unión europea asciende hasta el 64 por
ciento cinco veces más
pero ahora amigos ahora con la llegada
al poder de nuevos líderes como
bolsonaro macri este bloque parece estar
cambiando de rumbo y el primer gran
logro de toda esta nueva estrategia ha
sido precisamente el acuerdo con la
unión europea para firmar uno de los
tratados de libre comercio más grandes
jamás alcanzado hablamos de 32 países
casi 800 millones de personas y 19
millones de dólares de pib millones
hispanos claro y amigos ahora las
oportunidades que se abren son inmensas
especialmente para los países de
mercosur atentos
una oportunidad histórica
[Música]
aún no conocemos todos los detalles ni
tampoco la aplicación del acuerdo va a
ser inmediata pero sabéis que lo que ya
está sobre la mesa suena muy pero que
muy bien la unión europea' eliminará los
aranceles para el 92% de las
exportaciones de mercosur y otorgará
además un acceso en condiciones
preferentes a otros siete y medio por
ciento es decir menos del 1 por ciento
de los productos que mercosur vende a la
unión europea quedarán fuera del acuerdo
y esto evidentemente es algo que
impulsará un montón la competitividad de
las empresas sudamericanas y ojo porque
la unión europea es todo un coloso
comercial que devora productos de todo
el mundo como si no hubiera mañana la
unión europea es un mercado inmenso con
500 millones de habitantes que
representa el 20 por ciento de la
economía mundial es el primer inversor
con un stock que supera el 30 por ciento
de las inversiones globales que importa
el 17 por ciento del total de las
compras mundiales de bienes y servicios
informe del gobierno argentino
cada año la unión europea compra el
resto del planeta más de 2 billones de
dólares en todo tipo de productos pues
bien de toda esta cantidad poco más del
2% procede del bloque sudamericano para
que os hagáis una idea la unión europea
importa cada año más de corea del sur
que de todos los países de mercosur
juntos
sin embargo ahora este acuerdo le da la
oportunidad al brasil a la argentina a
uruguay ya paraguay de hacerse con una
porción cada vez más y más grande de
toda esta inmensa tarta
pensad lo que supone por ejemplo para el
campo que es el sector de sudamérica que
más exporta europa con este acuerdo ni
más ni menos que el 99 por ciento sus
exportaciones quedarán liberalizadas e
incluso más del 80 por ciento libres de
cualquier arancel e insisto no olvidéis
que europa importa cada año más de 120
mil millones de dólares en productos
agroalimentarios hablamos de un negocio
descomunal
por su parte el 91% de las exportaciones
de la unión europea al mercosur también
quedarán libres de aranceles lo que
supondrá por ejemplo que las empresas
brasileñas argentinas uruguayas y
paraguayas podrán acceder a la
tecnología de las máquinas alemanas con
mayor facilidad y mejores condiciones
[Música]
eso sí el acuerdo no se aplicará
completamente hasta dentro de 15 años
hasta entonces lo que veremos será una
aplicación progresiva con la idea
precisamente de dar tiempo a los países
sudamericanos para poner en marcha las
reformas que necesitan para competir
algo especialmente crítico en el caso de
argentina
por eso el grueso de las exportaciones
europeas se liberalizarán completamente
en un plazo de 10 a 15 años es decir
mercosur se beneficiará de este acuerdo
mucho antes que la mayoría de las
empresas europeas de hecho una vez que
el acuerdo entre en vigor las tres
cuartas partes de las exportaciones del
mercosur estarán libres de aranceles
frente a sólo el 13 por ciento de las
exportaciones europeas y no no penséis
que en europa no hay voces críticas por
todo esto
[Aplausos]
[Música]
sabéis qué es lo incomprensible es que
todavía hay políticos argentinos que se
quejan increíble estamos yendo
debilitados y a ciegas a un acuerdo que
será muy difícil que modifique las
condiciones del trabajo en la argentina
eso sí hay una cuestión importante en la
que conviene insistir un acuerdo de
libre comercio es una oportunidad pero
también es un riesgo si los países
deciden no competir con libre comercio
hay que competir ya no valen excusas
porque además el acuerdo va a establecer
su propia forma de trabajar es decir
mientras el acuerdo esté en vigor los
gobiernos no podrán boicotear el
comercio de las empresas extranjeras o
al menos estarán mucho más limitados
para hacerlos
pero la unión europea no termina todo
ahora mercosur va a por corea singapur
canadá a los países del eftá e incluso
hablan de eeuu y también por supuesto de
hacer lo que tendrían que haber hecho en
primer lugar mejorar la integración
económica de sus propios países miembros
veremos pronto un verdadero mercado
común sudamericano está mercosur
despegando por fin el tiempo dirá pero
ahora turno para ti hacia dónde tiene
que avanzar mercosur déjame tu respuesta
en los comentarios y también en esta
encuesta si este vídeo se ha resultado
interesante no olvidéis darle a like y
suscribiros a visual política con este
acuerdo américa del sur europa estarán
más juntas que nunca un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Música]